testimony on Capitol Hill today could
reveal explosive new details about the
alleged ties between the Trump campaign
and Russia former acting Attorney
General Sally Yates will appear before a
Senate committee Sally Yates was an
Obama administration holdover and a key
figure in the Russia investigation she
was fired soon after warning the White
House about then national security
adviser Michael Flynn's conversations
with Russian officials Jeff pjs is
outside the hearing room on Capitol Hill
Jeff good morning what will we hear well
good morning Sally aids testimony is
expected to include at least a few
bombshells and that's why you have some
members of Congress pushing for her to
appear and she will later on today the
former acting Attorney General is
expected to contradict public White
House official statements about this
issue multiple congressional and law
enforcement sources say Yates notified
the White House that former national
security adviser Michael Flynn was not
forthcoming with the vice president
about his contacts with the Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac according to
sources she also informed the White
House that Flynn was compromised the
president later fired Flynn but not
immediately and some members of Congress
want to know what took the White House
so long to respond to her concerns keep
in mind Flynn as former national
security adviser was handling the most
sensitive national security information
and Yates will not be the only big-name
testifying in his hearing room behind me
later on this afternoon also appearing
will be James clapper the former
Director of National Intelligence who
before his retirement in mid-january was
briefed on the most important details
connected to this Russian investigation
Gail all right thank you very much Jeff